it will be something that will live with
me for a long time you can't get over
how upsetting it is for me Africa is
home I was brought up there my parents
met and married there I went to school
there and I always wanted to go back
there to work I ended up getting the
posting of my dreams and I've been there
for about four or five years I've been
trying to do a story about trophy
hunting for quite a long time but we've
never managed to actually persuade
anyone to let us go along because there
was a lot of public outrage about the
killing of big beasts of the jungle
we wanted to get under the skin of
someone who'd paid to do it
my producer Nick basically you just
didn't give up hunting is a vast
industry in Africa a really really
difficult story to do it's not so
difficult to find organizations
governments who are willing to show you
their efforts to stop poachers from now
it's a very different thing to find
people who are willing to show you their
efforts to shoot an animal I just can't
have a delays and no experience after
two years of pursuing this nick who
managed to persuade a professional
hunter and his American client to let us
go along can you explain what the whole
point of being here is for your client
in particular this is a communal
Conservancy so in a communal Conservancy
the community benefits part of any
tourism or hunting that takes place
there's any one problem when we turned
up the professional hunter was fine the
client his American customer was fine
the American customers wife was not the
reason why we were loud on the shoot was
that we weren't allowed to identify the
hunter himself
I knew this as a cameraman before so my
whole forming was around being sensitive
to these requirements to go straight to
the Chobe River I'm dying to see
disaster then we realized that the
professional hunter was a character all
of his own this soft drinks wine via
everything else brilliant god when you
started the beautiful senses we're just
getting ready with everything we're
taking a whole load of equipment
Darwin's taking everything quite small
and mobile that also we're gonna have a
drone an idea of the landscape yeah and
I've got a load of fiction of GoPros and
of course every important what are these
again but not this just in case we don't
see them
so we've been told to be there now so we
better get a move on
lotta elephant walking up and down here
all looks like cars and cars they know
big old bulls like what we're looking
for a professional hunter was almost
better than the client because the
client wasn't really a hunter he was
paying to dress up in cocky uniform and
carry a gun that was his idea of a
holiday probably wouldn't were having
breakfast this morning they were having
breakfast too but the professional
hunter this is what he did day in day
out and he was a really engaging
character we are hunting the trophy
Ellison bought my hunting morals only
lead me and to call them an animal
that's going to die of old age anyway he
was passionate about what he saw as
conservation and passionate about
animals and yet he killed them I get the
sense from you you really love animals
and the nature how do you square that
with shooting in the killer it's a it's
a use it's a value if there didn't have
value there wouldn't be here and if we
don't maintain the value they wouldn't
be here the these all travel areas in
order for these people to tolerate these
animals and the losses they have in
props and trees and fruits and so on
there has to be a value
[Music]
most hunters that you need - will
certainly say that they are Pro
conservation I think the professional
hunter that we were with clearly wanted
to maintain the environment and to help
the environment he had persuaded himself
and the Namibian government was also
well behind this idea that the way to
conserve these big animals was to set
aside a certain number of licenses where
you controlled how many of the animals
were killed to see the destruction you
got money from it because people pay big
money hundreds of thousands of dollars
to go and shoot these animals and you
used that money to help protect the
other animals
[Music]
first time I've been on a hunt never
done anything like that before
and it involved trekking for hours and
hours and hours and I think the appeal
of being out in the bush is
understandable because it's this wild
jungle you can walk for hours and hours
and hours as we did and not see anyone
else they did very specific things like
following the spoor the footprints in
the mud
this ball wouldn't be old enough yet and
wouldn't it have even started reading it
so excited object smelling dung and
seeing how warm it was or how fresh it
was baby
small small though big big big edible
hearing listening the other elephant
breaking a tree it was a camera man's
dream location but ironically elephants
as big as they are we couldn't find any
you think it would be easy these huge
big elephants they've got to be easy to
spot know
when we eventually did locate these
elephants which took us forever we were
amazed at how silently they walked
through the forest we were right close
to them and you couldn't hear them these
huge animals it was really really
difficult to isolate an elephant that
the professional hunter was willing to
shoot these are all cars and cars young
bulls nothing yet there's no to get up
close with them is quite exciting and
exhilarating but it's quite terrifying
as well because they are incredibly
dangerous animals and with once what
they can kill you outright
but at the same time you feel quite
queasy about why you're there because
you know that ultimately one of these
amazing animals is going to get killed
[Music]
this is the sign of a big mature bull as
you think it's on its own
no there's older dia it's probably at
least the deer lists do your instincts
kick in at this stage where you think
right we are making progress a lot
elephant find a big old one and there's
a really good track yes but signs are
very positive
[Music]
this is one
everything became quite serious there
was a lot of tension in the air
[Music]
wait when that shot went off it was the
most horrific moment he had this noise
of the gunfire and then the elephants
screamed we're going we're all hoping
that it had been killed but
unfortunately it had only been wounded
it was just incredible how it just
disappeared into the forest
um it's we always prefer a quick ending
and that with all the Bulls around us
like that it was very very difficult to
get him closer and also then get her a
brain shot which is what we prefer was
that instantaneous that one moment we're
thinking oh my word what if we don't
find this this wounded elephant
and as it turned out it took us four
hours to track the elephants again it
was really shocking actually I was quite
surprised because obviously we've had a
big buildup we knew what was coming and
we sort of knew what the end result was
going to be and it was still really
shopping she's been right before me yes
we all don't get closer
[Music]
you can't get over how upsetting it is
when you see this huge big wild animal
just collapsing
nothing ever prepares you for that
moment of death
doesn't matter how hard and you art
these kind of things witnessing it at
first hand right there it will be
something that will live with me for a
long time the professional hunter and
the customer were also both shocked
that's always emotional he's taking
elephant Julius we killed him because we
love them I want them to survive my
young daughter Messina she massive in
the world not knows you and we have to
his sadness was also genuine it was a
story that was full of contradictions
because he had a hunter who said he
loved animals but then was also killing
them we've hunted our whole lives and we
have hunted all kinds of animals and yes
we killed them yes but we eat them too
this is an enormous amount of protein
it's got to feed 2,000 people today and
tomorrow and spoked in that they
wouldn't normally have also revenue that
wouldn't normally have we taking one old
bull out of population so that those
elephants we saw yesterday can occupy
this area part of the conservation
things they stripped the animal and
distributed the meat to everyone in the
community that was also very shocking
seeing them market the animal with
machetes we watched it all it went from
this big animal to like a butcher's
carcass it's hard and what to be moved
by that
[Music]
it seems pretty horrendous and I still
can't understand even having spent a lot
of time with professional hunters who
were passionate about conservation
I still don't myself see why someone
would want to shoot an animal let alone
pay hundreds of thousands of dollars for
the privilege but I also understand
their perspective when it comes to
conservation and so I find that a
difficult argument to get my head round
still both the customer and the
professional hunter was sort of easy
people to criticize I think lots of
people who'd be absolutely appalled
watching someone basically fire at
point-blank range between an animal's
eyes it was not really a fair contest
the professional hunter he knew that he
was going to get a lot of criticism and
to be fair with him he had a message
when his was that Namibia's elephant
population was going up because of the
way they handled killing a certain
number was conserving the rest for the
good of the the rest that is a
controversial tactic but as far as the
Namibian authorities concerned it's
working